[Music]
concrete is the most widely used
construction material in the world it
can be found in swaths of city pavements
bridges that span vast rivers and the
tallest skyscrapers on earth but the
sturdy substance does have a weakness
it's prone to catastrophic cracking that
costs tens of billions of dollars to
repair each year but what if we could
avoid that problem by creating concrete
that heals itself this idea isn't as
far-fetched as it may seem it boils down
to an understanding of how concrete
forms and how to exploit that process to
our benefit concrete is a combination of
coarse stone and sand particles called
aggregates that mix with cement a
powdered blend of clay and limestone
when water gets added to this mix the
cement forms a paste and coats the
aggregates quickly hardening through a
chemical reaction called hydration
eventually the resulting material grows
strong enough to prop up buildings that
climb hundreds of meters into the sky
while people have been using a variety
of recipes to produce cement for over
4,000 years concrete itself has a
surprisingly short lifespan after 20 to
30 years natural processes like concrete
shrinkage excessive freezing and thawing
and heavy loads can trigger cracking and
it's not just big breaks that count tiny
cracks can be just as dangerous concrete
is often used as a secondary support
around steel reinforcements in this
concrete even small cracks can channel
water oxygen and carbon dioxide that
corrode the steel and lead to disastrous
collapse on structures like bridges and
highways that are constantly in use
detecting these problems before they
lead to catastrophe becomes a huge and
costly challenge but not doing so would
also endanger thousands of lives
fortunately we're already experimenting
with ways this material could start
fixing itself and some of these
solutions are inspired by concrete's
natural self-healing mechanism when
water enters these tiny cracks it
hydrates the concrete's calcium oxide
the resulting calcium hydroxide reacts
with the carbon dioxide in the air
starting a process called a Taj inist
healing where microscopic calcium
carbonate crystals form and gradually
fill the gap
unfortunately these crystals can only do
so much healing cracks that are less
than 0.3 millimeters wide material
scientists have figured out how to heal
cracks up to twice that size by adding
hidden glue into the concrete mix if we
put adhesive filled fibers and tubes
into the mixture they'll snap open when
a crack forms releasing their sticky
contents and sealing the gap but
adhesive chemicals often behave very
differently from concrete and over time
these adhesives can lead to even worse
cracks so perhaps the best way to heal
large cracks is to give concrete the
tools to help itself scientists have
discovered that some bacteria and fungi
can produce minerals including the
calcium carbonate found in a Taj inist
healing
experimental blends of concrete include
these bacterial or fungal spores
alongside nutrients in their concrete
mix where they could lie dormant for
hundreds of years
when cracks finally appear in water
trickles into the concrete the spores
germinate grow and consume the nutrient
soup that surrounds them modifying their
local environment to create the perfect
conditions for calcium carbonate to grow
these crystals gradually fill the gaps
and after roughly three weeks the
hard-working microbes can completely
repair cracks up to almost one
millimeter wide when the crack seal the
bacteria or fungi will make spores and
go dormant once more ready to start a
new cycle of self-healing when cracks
form again although this technique has
been studied extensively we still have a
ways to go before incorporating it in
the global production of concrete but
these spores have huge potential to make
concrete more resilient and long-lasting
which could drastically reduce the
financial and environmental cost of
concrete production eventually these
microorganisms may force us to
reconsider the way we think about our
cities bringing our Anatomy
jungles to life have you heard of
metallic glass check out this lesson to
learn about yet another mind-boggling
material or check out this playlist for
more fascinating inventions from the
course of human history
[Music]